hey you guys
so we're finally getting around to
talking about
this
iconic
cult film movie's a masterpiece the film
that birthed a million old internet
memes
every time you see that very famous meme
of like the drawing of the face that
says you don't say on it that's from
this movie that's nicholas cage
and this is
vampire's kiss yeah now you had never
seen this no
oh my goodness i can't believe you've
never seen this so yeah this came out in
1989 movies and masterpiece
yeah well i'm glad you liked it i always
really really like this movie
think about that it's not like the weird
this kind of occupies like a strange
area where it's not really a good movie
but
it's a really really entertaining one i
think it's good
yeah i think it's good yeah
it's this is kind of like a richard
chase type situation
where you're not sure whether a guy has
turned into a vampire or not
i guess no i guess he's he's crazy he
thinks he's the vampire
um but he's having
hallucinations that kind of support his
belief but then they show what what's
really going on
now i don't know if it's some kind of
psychic attack by a vampire like
creature in another dimension
it's open to interpretation yeah i mean
they leave it open to that uh
possibility as well if you want to go
that way it might be a vampire attack
and it's just that you've never it's
just that uh
it attacks you psychically
you know and
most of it is the illusion it could be
that it leaves it open
or the dude just is a dude like richard
chase i think is is one that his name
richard chase yeah
yeah we did a show about him yeah he was
good he was convinced he was a vampire
and that he was falling apart and that
he had to kill people and drink blood
and all that kind of crap
he he he's a guy like that even though
he's
he's not a bad guy he just starts to do
a lot of bad stuff because he thinks
he's a vampire well i would argue with
you there because i do absolutely think
he's a bad well he's a bad guy in the
sense that he's just like a raging
[ __ ] like even before he thinks he
turns into a vampire he's a yuppie yeah
well yeah but i repeat myself
raging [ __ ] like especially in the
1980s you really had all these i really
kind of feel like this movie is almost
like the proto-american psycho yeah
because american psycho is kind of like
that too where it's like evil yuppy but
it's like you don't know if he actually
did all the [ __ ]
that i mean but the thing about
vampire's kiss is that even though he
probably didn't actually get bit by a
vampire um
by all accounts he did actually do the
rape at the burger which we'll talk
about so he did actually do the things
my interpretation is that the the kiss
of the vampire the bite of the vampire
it's plausible that it's happening in
another dimension it's like spiritual
and it turns you into a vampire that way
you know i mean in another dimension and
then if you think you've turned into a
vampire you're actually crazy
but you might be it's just you got to
see the movie i mean it's he's got some
plausible deniability he's definitely
not a vampire in the way that he thinks
he is
but it could be that the vampire mythos
is based upon dudes that that this
happens to where it's mostly notional
yeah that's a good way of putting it
yeah
that's why i was interpreting like
here's another way of interpreting
interpreting a vampire a case of
vampirism
is that you're imagining it
but it's
it did happen to you though
something happened to you well the thing
about it i think and i think the kind of
you know what they're trying to get out
with the movie is that nicholas cage's
character who in the movie is named
peter lowe and he's like this literary
agent like you said he's a yuppie and he
doesn't really he seems very lonely like
he lives alone he's just goes around
like you know with one night stands and
all this other kind of stuff and
he seems a little bit like i said very
isolated kind of self-loathing but he's
also like really really just all he's
worried about his work and like uh you
know getting ahead in his job and stuff
and he obviously has some issues because
he goes to a therapist but i think that
the issues that he has particularly the
issues that he has with his isolation
the issues that he has with women it
kind of like
mutates into
you know these little things
insignificant things happen like toward
the beginning like he takes this girl
home for a one-night stand and like a
bat gets into his apartment and like
little things like that start happening
and it almost kind of like triggers
something in his head where he just like
has this full-blown psychosis which
maybe would have come about in a
different way had that bat not come in
there it would have like expressed
itself completely differently or it was
a psychic attack
yeah like i said that's that's a totally
valid interpretation that might have
been the vampire i think you're meant to
be yeah i mean you're meant to believe
that
none of this stuff really happened like
he didn't really get bit by a vampire
like they do kind of give you clues that
that didn't happen but at the same time
they did kind of leave it open so that
if you wanted to think that he got bit
by a vampire like you could totally make
it so he did i mean he's tripping you
know and he and he's going through all
the damn vampire [ __ ]
uh uh tropes you know he's even turned
to the dab
couch upside down and made a coffee
he buy he buys fake really bad vampire
teeth
he's eating roaches like renfield
oh my god he thinks he's a real winner
he thinks he's a real winner but in
reality he's basically a homeless bum
walking around it's [ __ ] funny
although he never really goes homeless
it's just that the inside of his
apartment looks like a million dollars
an apartment worth millions of dollars
even yeah in new york city like even
back in those days in the 80s it would
have been worth millions of dollars and
it's just looks like a homeless person
lives there it's just rubble and [ __ ] he
even dies by getting a skate driven
through him you know what i mean it's
just [ __ ] funny
so it's almost like a self-fulfilling
yeah because he thinks he's a vampire he
thinks that's the only way he can be
killed
it's
to me it's it's it's it is a vampire
story
this fits all the tropes of a vampire
story it's just that what would it
really look like if vampires existed
and that's the [ __ ] funny part
i mean can we talk about nicholas cage
oh he's [ __ ] great um
yeah he wins the [ __ ] out when people
talk about i think he's at pete cage in
this like at least until the wicker man
remake um
this one when people talked about crazy
nicolas cage and i'm not saying he's not
crazy in other movies too but he's been
like relatively restrained in some other
films but when people talk about crazy
nicholas cage this is probably the movie
that they're talking about i got a lot
of respect from nicholas cage i do as
well he
he'll be in anything i think you know
i think his he had a bunch of irs
problems he had he had to clear up
well if he's cleared him up by now i
mean that's because he made a lot of
money but he spent it on dumb things
usually he bought castles and a
crocodile and yeah if i could just
handle money all right just crazy [ __ ]
and um shrunken heads but you know you
live and learn you know
or or you don't
but
he'd be in anything
but he never telephoned that [ __ ] in you
you got
you got what you paid for when you hired
nicholas cage to be in the [ __ ] movie
and he's been in some great movies and
he's been in some piece of [ __ ] movies
but even if in a piece of [ __ ] movie you
got your cages worth
yeah you go like okay all right he's
he's doing what he does
recently his best one would be i would
say mandy and color out of space pretty
good some people didn't like colorado
space but mandy's a [ __ ] masterpiece
yeah mandy's great yeah absolutely
fantastic but well most men never have a
movie like that in their career they
wait a whole career to have a movie like
that but i [ __ ] love i love mandy
i mean well like i said you have to
respect nicholas cage for
yeah like a lot of times he would pick
projects just because you know he needed
the money which like i said it's a job
so you know that's what you do and he's
not like the best with managing money
which again not everyone not everybody
is but i mean when you hired him to be
nicholas cage
he'll be nicholas cage and he just seems
to have a really good time with it and
he really seems to be having a good time
with the
utterly bizarre acting choices that he
made in this movie but the thing about
it is that
if this movie had not had nicolas cage
at its core it wouldn't work would
anybody even remember it really no he
made this i kind of feel like this i
mean and i'm not saying like the other
actors that are good like jennifer beals
is in it yeah uh maria conchito lonzo is
in it yeah like there's other like
elizabeth isn't it there's a lot of like
good actors in this but
the fact that his performance is so out
there
is really what makes people
you know really like still talk about
this movie to this day why
every like there's so many quotable
lines so many quotable scenes just he
just decided for whatever reason that he
was just going to completely go for it
and it's just really really entertaining
another good one he did lately was the
one where he didn't say a word to the
whole damn movie just fought the damn
animatronic monsters yeah willy's
wonderland willie's wonderland it's
another good one yeah let's see that one
that's good but yeah the pig was good
yeah i like my i liked pagoda
anticlimactic pig yeah i mean and he was
restrained in that yeah but like i said
i mean if you're talking and nicholas
cage was actually quite young in
vampire's kiss i believe he was only 24
when this was made he had made some
movies before this obviously he was in
valley girl
and i think raising arizona came out
like the year before this so he'd been
in like some big movies and stuff but
uh this was kind of like i'm not
entirely sure you know the accent that
he does in this yeah
that's his yep
i'm not sure like what i saw somebody
else like maybe it was on like the
wikipedia page or something they called
it like
his
quasi-transylvanian accent i don't even
think it was that i couldn't figure out
was it
british he was he was trying to sound
like a yuppie i guess like from
california like a california yuppie like
some dude from malibu
i guess even though he was in new york
city yeah
he's trying to be like he's from malibu
and um
but
it did kind of go a little when when he
started to turn vampire he started to do
a little bit of transylvania on top of
malibu
[Laughter]
just it's just [ __ ] good you know he
he's
he's a fraud you know what i mean the
character is a fraud
and then
this fraudulent character thinks he's a
vampire
for some reason
i think i think i think the movie some i
think that i think the movie kind of
supports the idea that
a vampires might be psychic this might
be like a psychic vampire
the [ __ ]
that came in and it might have been a
vampire bat
and it
launched some kind of psychic attack on
him
which
drives you crazy
and you think you're a vampire
and you start acting like a vampire or
you start acting the way you think a
vampire should act
yeah which just leads to a whole bunch
of trouble and
you kind of lose touch with reality and
then you die the way a vampire dies with
the stake through your heart yeah and
this might be what happens to vampires
all vampires
maybe
maybe well i was kind of thinking that i
was kind of thinking while we were
watching the movie again last night i
was thinking particularly the scene
toward the end where nicolas cage is
like in his mind he's talking to his
therapist like in the office and he's
all suave with his suit and everything
but in reality he's covered with blood
his hair is all [ __ ] up he looks like
a bomb and he's yelling at a wall yeah
and like sitting there like holding a
stake and i was thinking to myself i
wonder like sometimes when you're
walking around like a streets of a big
city and there's like some crazy person
walking around and i'm kind of like you
know it could be that
they're they're going they're vampires
so that's what they're going through
right now
yeah so this was actually written by a
guy named
um what was his name joseph minion and
he was the same guy that wrote after
hours the martin scorsese film and so
which was also kind of like the same
sort of thing not as extreme as this one
obviously but it was kind of like a
black comedy sort of like a you know
streets of new york type of thing and
joseph minion said that he actually
wrote this story
um
because of his relationship with his
then girlfriend or wife or whatever and
i guess they were having a lot of
problems clearly and he started
perceiving her as like a vampire that
was like sucking him dry or whatever and
uh so he kind of wrote this really and
he was going through like a lot of
depression so he kind of wrote this
about
his sort of toxic relationship with her
like i was like portraying her as a
vampire and i think there's a lot to be
said that the movie
it's
the reason that i said that uh the the
peter lowe character who obviously has
like some issues with women like i said
he doesn't seem to have a girlfriend he
doesn't seem to be close to anyone in
particular he's very arrogant
and
he just kind of goes to the club every
night and picks up like one night stands
and he doesn't really seem to
particularly care about you know calling
the back or doing anything like that but
then like deep down like he seems to
tell his therapist that all he wants is
love and blah blah but he can't really
seem to handle it so i think that when
the vampire uh comes into his life who's
actually
her name is rachel and she's played by
jennifer beals now what it is is he just
sees her in a bar and i guess he fixates
on her because she's beautiful or
whatever and he sort of
has this fantasy about
because he likes to be really arrogant
and controlling and everything like that
which they kind of get into with his
relationship with his assistant like one
of the secretaries sorry that's my phone
ringing
one of his secretaries alva who he just
mercilessly like brow beats and you know
shits on like pretty much every
chance he gets
so i think that he has this weird thing
about
the fact that he's surrendering to this
supposed vampire a woman who's kind of
like has him under her control and so he
it's coming out like in other ways where
he has to like assert control again like
over this other woman that's in his
office that does that is not doesn't
have any power and stuff like that so i
kind of feel like there's a lot of that
sort of dynamic going on as well but
he's perceiving it as vampirism almost
like well she's a supernatural creature
and so i don't have
you know i can't fight against her you
know what i'm saying so i think there's
some of that going on too but like i
said if you haven't seen this movie so
basically what happens he's like a
literary agent right
and he works at whatever the hell i
can't remember i think they say the name
of the publishing yeah back when you
make millions of dollars dealing with
books
well yeah well i mean some still do
because look at [ __ ] people like jk
rowling
they still make bajillions of dollars um
but yeah so he so he works there and
he's like an executive and he's a dick
but like it seems like they have a
couple scenes like with other executives
like in his office and they're all
douches too um because the ones kind of
horrifying scene where he actually
chases alva into the bathroom
and starts like screaming at her and
stuff like that they all just think it's
funny you know i mean even though she's
so scared that she's like threaded to
pull a gun on him and stuff
so so there's that kind of thing so he's
not any more of an [ __ ] than anybody
else that works there but then like as
this as his sanity begins to crumble or
as the vampire asserts more control over
him whichever way you want to spin it
um
he gets more and more like dangerous you
know what i mean because the whole thing
with
because a large part of the plot is
taken up with his relationship with alva
the woman at the office he's played by
maria cachetta alonso there's this whole
plot point about
this client who wants this old contract
and he even says to the dude on the
phone uh you know the the client says oh
it's not that big a deal i just kind of
wanted it like don't rush
but
peter nicholas cage he makes it seem
like oh my god this guy's going to leave
if like he doesn't get this contract
right now so he uh so he makes
her
stay and like look for this contract
which was misfiled
and he just like
relentlessly like [ __ ] brow beats her
about it and like abuses her about it
makes her stay like all night all this
other kind of stuff so like i said it
gets to a point where she gets so scared
she has a gun it's like and he ends up
actually like raping her at the end
uh which is horrifying but that's kind
of another thing that feeds into his
delusion too is because the gun that she
has they established that it only has
blanks in it
and so there's a scene in here do not do
this he sticks a damn pistol in his
mouth and pulls the trigger trying to
kill himself with blanks and it doesn't
kill him in reality that would it would
still kill you yeah so i'm sure like
when they were shooting the movie i'm
sure they'd just use caps or whatever
the hell but um because he does actually
stick it in his mouth and it does look
like it goes off yeah but i do that yeah
but seriously don't do that even if it's
possible it's a real round it's just
that there's no projectile in there but
that gas coming out of there will blow a
hole right through you yeah but that's
the thing but so
he doesn't know that they're blanks or
whatever like i said we're just going by
movie logic and so he puts the thing in
his mouth and like shoots it off a
couple times and the fact that he
doesn't die
confirms to him that he's a vampire and
that the only way he can be killed is a
stake through the heart because like
obviously he shot himself and it didn't
do anything
and the other famous scene too was where
he ate the cockroach
yeah uh and he had to swallow it but he
didn't chew it he did
he said i saw an interview with him
about it and he said well actually we
had to do that twice yeah and it was his
idea dumbass they were originally gonna
have him like i think originally they
were like well you think you didn't cut
it you can just have like raw eggs or
something like that he's like no it
should be a cockroach because he wanted
it to be like super super shocking and
like you said he might have been making
a reference to like renfield type of
stuff like eating insects which to me
like eating a roach as gross as it is i
still can't really watch it um but
because it just it's so nasty
but doing that like kind of goes
more toward like the vampire myth than
the eggs would have i feel like
but
yeah so basically you're just watching
this guy
losing his [ __ ] mind like over the
course see i don't think that
i don't know like i said i don't think
that she was really a vampire
because at the end
when when he goes up to her at the end
like when they're at the nightclub like
after he's like after he raped alva
after he kills that girl in the
nightclub like with the teeth
and then he sees rachel in the club and
she doesn't wreck it or she barely
recognizes no i don't think she was the
vampire he thought she was the vampire
and he's like opening her mouth look at
her teeth look at this that was just
that was just the form that it took
i think the vampire was the bat
tom really really wants there to be a
vampire this may be it was not all it is
it was just in his mind it was in his
mind he you know it gave it gave him a
form to to focus on and it was somehow
really saw at the club i guess so yeah
but yeah it was he thought it was her
it's it's plausible that there's
a psychic vampire in in this story yeah
i mean that's too yeah it's totally
plausible but like i said i always
interpreted it as he was just like
losing his [ __ ] [ __ ] i think both
both psychic vampires making him go
crazy yeah that's true yeah and i think
that he fixed it well like i said i
think he fixed it on the vampire thing
because of the bat but and then he tells
when he's still relatively normal i mean
he's nicholas cage so he's obviously
never normal but when he's relatively
normal by nicholas cage standards
after the bat thing happens
like the bat flies in the apartment he
tells the therapist that when the bat
came in like he felt kind of turned on
by it but he doesn't really elaborate
and then when she asks him about it
again like the next at the next session
he says he doesn't remember what she's
talking about well the bat might have
been the vampires just disguised as a
bat
it turned into a bit yeah vampires
turned into bats right yeah i know that
so it might have been a damn vampire
because the thing about it is like he
takes rachel home and i was kind of
thinking well maybe rachel he did have a
one-night stand with her maybe because
she knew his name like in the club at
the end and she was like oh yeah like
peter right like how have you been so i
guess maybe they did sleep together at
some point like in the past
but the thing about it is that
i don't know like i kind of feel like
after that happened like the very day
after that happened because he brings
her home and he
she either bites him or he perceives
that she bites him but the next morning
he's like in there uh making coffee or
whatever and he brings the coffee into
the and there's nobody there and he
holds the coffee cup out to like nobody
yeah and it's clear that nobody's been
there no he's crazy and it happens a
couple is and it happens like pretty
early like it happens a couple times
where
um
where he's like talking to her as though
she's like hey come in the shower with
me and blah blah there's obviously
nobody there no
so it doesn't mean there's no vampire
though that's true all right just i
think that that bat that came in was a
vampire
and it
made him [ __ ] crazy
all right so then the vampire phenomenon
started happening
but it's all internal
there's no people yeah and he thought
that vampire was that woman from the
club so he's getting very confused but
it's like a psychic vampire yeah because
like he keeps seeing her you know she's
like talking to him she comes there and
like drains his blood all the time yeah
and it's manipulating him and stuff but
it's just that's just the form he chose
yeah for the vampire to have but it's
not
it's not really there it's like in
another dimension
okay you know what i mean like something
out of vivarium
they went into another dimension they
weren't there anymore they were in
another dimension it's another vampire
yeah so there was a vampire in another
dimension but yeah i mean
dimension of incre of insanity i can't
imagine that anybody if you have not
seen this movie you really have to see
it because
honestly
i know there's like tons of memes about
nicholas cage and there's tons of like
scenes and there's tons of lines of this
um i mean probably the best stuff like
when he jumps up on the desk there you
are like you know what i mean like which
was again just him doing that
um and the scene where he's in his
therapist office and he's has a [ __ ]
freak out about how things could get
misfiled how does he how do things get
misfiled it's like it's alphabetical a b
c and he just does that kind of [ __ ]
yeah uh and it's just so [ __ ] great
that he keeps us that [ __ ] thing with
his arms
not one time you know what i mean which
he said he actually got from uh mick
jagger
that's what he said and he said that was
all very choreographed i was on an
interview with him earlier where he said
that because that's probably one of the
most famous scenes in the movie uh he
said yeah i've choreographed all those
hand movements like for my cat so i'm
sure the cat was like horrified like
what are you doing daddy you know what i
mean but it's just oh my god everything
in this is just so good just like the
way and when he goes to buy the teeth
and i like that he goes in the costume
shop and there's this kindly old man
who's wearing like a satanic like a
pentagram shirt which i think is funny
and he shows him these really nice
vampire fangs which are like made of uh
what were they made of they were kind of
like fiberglass or something and he told
him they were 20
and he's like uh i don't have twenty
dollars well i got these cheapy plastic
ones for three dollars and fifty cents
and he's like yeah give me those but if
you notice i don't think they made a big
uh thing about this but i like uh kind
of all these little subtle touches and i
realized subtle isn't usually a word
that people uh use when they talk about
this movie
but when he kills the girl in the
nightclub
he's actually not wearing those like he
was and then i guess he was trying to
like gummer and it wasn't working so he
took them out
and then like he bitter and killed her
and then because you see him like slip
him back in like afterward because
obviously i don't think you could kill
anybody by biting them with plastic
fangs they would probably just break uh
so i like that little subtle touch but i
mean when he first goes in that
nightclub and he's walking around with
his eyes all big like like looking for a
[ __ ] victims and stuff it's just
hilarious i mean nicholas cage
he is
just so weird and i just love
that he's just
weird and it's like he doesn't even care
and like i said if he had not been in
this movie
i don't know
i don't know if this movie would have
the reputation that it had because it's
funny but i think a lot of it one it's
dark humor it's a british director
um
dark humor black comedy is a hard sell
particularly in the united states
and this movie uh tanked
at the box office i think it cost only
four million to make but it made less
than a million at the box office and got
terrible terrible reviews uh most people
yeah most people complaining that you
know nicholas cage was like so over the
top and he was unsympathetic and blah
blah i'm like well he wasn't supposed to
be sympathetic he was a jerk you know
what i mean it's just like the
entertainment value came from watching
it people didn't go completely batshit
yeah so this is definitely one of those
movies that
was not appreciated at the time
but
as people saw it on cable and you know
on vhs and stuff like that as the 80s
and 90s went on people started to like
appreciate it because like oh my god
this is like what's great is that it is
a vampire movie yeah there is vampire
stuff in it like people do get bitten
but it fits within vampire lore yeah but
you could totally read it as there was
no vampire
ever oh you know and he just was like
imagining all of it or there was some
kind of weird extra-dimensional psychic
vampire or there was an actual vampire
but it was just like shape-shifting or
whatever no it was in his mind yeah i
mean yeah like you said like a psychic
vampire maybe but i mean just every
single thing
nicolas cage just takes all the he
doesn't even chew up the scenery man
it's just like he just like houses the
[ __ ] he's just like all of the scene or
just all of it but i think that that
this movie needed that because it's kind
of like
the premise i've seen movies with more
ridiculous
ideas like more ridiculous premises this
isn't that out there but i think
a premise like this
i think really does benefit from
somebody like leaning into the
ridiculousness and i think nicholas cage
maybe sensed that
and
said i'm just gonna be as [ __ ]
ridiculous as possible like just with no
explanation why am i talking in this
weird accent no explanation why am i
jumping up on this desk like this and
like pointing people why am i scatting
like while i'm well you know why is he
doing all this yeah what is scatting
it's when you do that boop but
that kind of thing that's called
scatting it's a jazz term okay but yeah
so he does so he's doing that it's like
why is he doing half the [ __ ] that he's
doing this movie because he's nicholas
[ __ ] cage you know what i mean and
you have to think too that this was kind
of early in his career
and he was trying to i don't know if he
was necessarily trying to build a brand
but he definitely wanted
some attention he wanted stardom and
stuff like that and he just decided for
whatever reason this is the way that
we're gonna do it
and it didn't i think it didn't work at
the time
but
in hindsight i think a lot of people
this is like their best their their
favorite performance it worked it's just
because it's just so out there they
worked they just it was just uh they
weren't ready for it i guess i mean and
the thing is i think he had done
moonstruck too like a year before this
which was like a big that won some
oscars and stuff like that too and i
think he was relatively restrained in
that or like i said as normal as he can
be um so the fact that this came out
again black comedy they don't usually do
really well uh at the because people are
like well is it it's not overtly funny
um people don't really like tend to like
dark humor it's not like a you know an
easy sell and
so so it had that aspect and then it had
nicolas cage acting completely bonkers
in it and i think people didn't really
get it but
people get it now it was just one of
those movies that i think wasn't
appreciated at the time which is kind of
a shame but at least people
at least people dig it now uh if then
like i said if you want to see
crazy nicholas cage at peak crazy
this is probably it like i said until
like uh you know the wicker man remake
where does it you know how to get burned
how to get burned like that or that the
babies the bees that kind of thing uh
this is along those lines i mean just
everything in this is just completely
strange and wonderful
and it's just such a fun movie you know
and i'm glad you liked it too because i
didn't know if you liked it at first
because you kept like i don't know like
i said i can never tell but then like
after it was over you were just like
like man that was a masterpiece
it's goofy as [ __ ] but yeah i actually
do kind of love it uh so yeah vampires
kiss 1989
have you seen it have you not seen it uh
do you think it's funny or do you just
think it's ridiculous let me know in the
comments and that will do it for this
movie retrospective we will see you guys
on the next one
bye
you